Yeah,
believe some other things.
This is where I think he gets a little
bit optimistic,
but
Rogers is one of those optimists you
really have to contend with.
Now he believed,
and I think this is a classical
Protestant belief,
this as well,
that what evil was was basically the
absence of good and that people had a
strong intrinsic impulse towards the
good that you could help them realize
and the way you help them realize.
That was by setting the preconditions
for the emergence of that good and he
believed that the preconditions were
the provision of a space for
communication
where there was no judgment in the sense
of rejection.
And so here's the Rogerian theory with
regards to therapeutic endeavor.
Now the first thing is,
and this seems critical and I think
Rogers was right about this,
that the client has to want to change,
and this is.
This is a funny thing about therapy
because my observation has been that
it's not something you can impose on
people unless they've decided that
things could be better and that
alterations in,
in,
in something they're doing might make it
better.
It's a nonstarter.
And so I've had clients who were court
ordered to attend therapy and that's
just complete waste of time,
especially if they're more on the
psychopath,
that gift of things because you're just,
if they don't want to change,
they're not going to learn.
And this is actually another Rogerian
principle and because Roger's had an
educational philosophy as well and the
educational philosophy was students will
not learn things that are not relevant
to them.
And so one of the teachers duties was to
make the material at hand relevant
because that would
help the students remember it.
Why remembered if it's not relevant to.
One of the things I tried to do in my
lectures,
I try to tell people when I'm lecturing,
why they should know this.
And the fundamental answer always,
if you push it down far enough,
is that if you know this,
your life will go better and so will the
life of people around you.
So you should listen.
Because then there's some things that
are sharp and pointy that you will run
into while you're wandering around in
the fall.
So,
and,
and that's the fundamental issue.
It's,
it's necessary to know these things and
so if you're dealing with someone who
hasn't decided that there's something
wrong and that they have something to do
about it,
then maybe they could change that would
make things better.
You're not going anywhere,
and Rogers would also say that's
actually a precondition for a
relationship period because he didn't
really make much of a distinction
between a therapeutic relationship and a
genuine relationship because he thought
the genuine relationships with
therapeutic and so one of the principles
that you can extract from that is that
if you're in a relationship,
one useful proposition is that,
well,
you're pretty perfect,
but you're probably not quite as perfect
as you could be.
And so it's possible that your partner,
no matter how deeply flawed they are,
might now and then have something to say
to you that would,
if you incorporated,
would bring you to an even higher state
of perfection.
Right?
And so that's,
that means you have to listen.
And it's worse than that.
And this again is a Rogerian
observation.
You might have to help them criticize
you because maybe they're not very good
at it.
You know,
and so there's something they're trying
to tell you and they're stumbling way
and it's,
it's an actual thing,
but they can't articulate it and so it'd
be easy for you just to,
especially if you're trying to use
language instrumentally and to get away
with it just to,
while you could even make fun of the way
they're poorly articulating the problem,
that's a really good one because then
you can convince them not to do such
things in the future.
But if you take the other stance,
which is,
well,
I've got some things to learn and you've
got some things to learn and you've got
some things to teach me and I've got
some things to teach you and God only
knows when that's gonna happen,
but it might happen.
So the object of the conversation is for
each person to help the other person
make their point.
You know?
And that's a lot different than winning
the argument.
And I can tell you one thing,
you will not win an argument with any
intimate partner ever because you're not
playing the game of the argument.
You're playing the game of iterated
arguments across time and so if you win
an argument,
you just set up another one winning and
solving the problem and the same thing,
so from a Rogerian perspective,
winning would be the maintenance of your
current self structure at the cost of
failure to integrate some disintegrated
element of the phenomenological realm.
Maybe it'd be the unhappiness of your
partner.
That might be one of them.
Now you can.
If you win the argument,
that's the rationalization issue.
Fundamentally you don't have to change,
but the fact is you do have to change
because the way you are is giving rise
to this situation and that's not going
to change unless you fix it.
So winning an argument and fixing
something.
Those are completely different things.
You fix the thing.
It goes away and often couples have to
have conflict because there's no
difference between conflict and
thinking.
Thinking is a form of Lore.
It's just that you,
you,
you make it an interior form of war,
right?
You can't have accomplished without
conflict because life is different,
difficult and people differ from one
another.
So they have different value structures
and so you can't just ignore that you
have to set up a dialogue because it's
not necessarily obvious clues,
right?
Of course rogers bleed that in the
therapeutic round two.
So he thought if therapy is something
that emerged as a consequence of the
adoption of certain axiomatic
presuppositions and those were
things could be better than they are and
you could make them that way and that's
also true for me.
And then the next presumption is,
well maybe we can figure out how to do
that in a collaborative with
collaborative communication.
So Rogers believed that the therapist
was just as transformed during the
therapeutic process as the person.
In fact,
if that wasn't happening then whatever
was happening wasn't the kind of healing
therapy that Rogers would like to have
happen.
And he also said that's all.
I'll read you something he said later,
but he also pointed out quite strongly
that that's why people don't really like
to listen.
You know,
like maybe there's some flaw in
yourself.
Structure at some fundamental level,
fundamentally axiomatic level,
you know,
maybe you're narcissistic.
That'd be a good one.
And you know,
if you listen to people,
they're going to tell you you're
narcissistic.
Well,
you don't want to find that out because
it's going to blow a huge hole and
you're gonna blow a huge hole in
yourself.
Structure that's not very fun.
But
hypothetically,
that beats running into the obstacles
that you will run into if you're
narcissistic repeatedly as you move
forward through life.
So you can either live with your flaws
are correct.
And then the,
the pathway to correction is dialogue,
communication.